[Music]
achievement in directing for the shape
of water Guillermo del Toro and also
joining mr. del Toro for the winners for
both Best Motion Pictures shape of water
is Guillermo and J miles Dale okay let
me try and be a little fair here let's
start with two to nine and then I'll go
two to seven a we're just gonna get my
mic and then we'll get going Felicia is
Guillermo viendo en todas kuso
mr. Kerem necesario did our Paredes
answer in Spanish and English in Avignon
parami is importante porque el Modelo
us a year now and get DNA you know como
home in Italian the superficial peroneal
Morello case hermoso case abuelo here
came another severe Sinister's
compromise is con dar el Haddad singers
compromise con a really rad pero la
verdad si creo que la fantasy Italian
condo celebrity muchas veces NOLA
tomamos como dare he insta ceremonia es
muy bueno para me que una de las casas
Marika's a Latin America's laughable
asean la posibilidad a cenar mundos
creaturas a fabulous parabolas pertinent
A's para los momentos de fishiness he
espero que los jimenez estan bien lo que
trabajan en las Artes plastic as in
discrete or and and seen qiansun can
fantastic resume camino a la verdad
nope once again we're coming down and
she's 78 and then we all go to 113 I
need a pair plunge in one news of China
at the Golden Globes I asked you about
how you balance it like darkness and
and you created a meme that's gone all
around the world and affected millions
of people so the question is how do we
keep that how do we help you keep that
going how do we stop the scapegoating of
Mexico and really reaffirm your unique
and magnificent culture thank you no I
think that every time we can demonstrate
in any forum be it sports science arts
culture anywhere what we have to bring
to the world discourse to the world
conversation is extremely important in
this extremely important when we do it
to remember where we're from because
this is honoring your roots and honoring
your country now I'm going - next stop
is I'm going to see my mom and my dad
this week I'm going back home with this
- with this two babies 1:39 hi here in
the middle oh hi go hi congratulations
um you spoke fondly about Fox
Searchlight on stage and I wonder if you
know anything about the studio's future
have you talked to anybody at Disney
about it have they reached out to you
what can you say about that as they say
here is about my bay range now I have
all my favorite but what I know is I'm
continuing conversations with with them
about future projects you know and you
form bonds with the studio but your form
bonds with individuals with people that
support you on whatever did I ask for
our goals or stays you continue creating
thank you we're going to 179 and then 16
how is this a victory for you know
Hollywood north and the production going
on in Canada so much of this was done in
Toronto I will let Myles
answer that - what I will say when we
started this month and I we talked very
very seriously about creating this movie
with heads of departments from Canada we
wanted to you know I've been there
working for more than half a decade
continuously and I wanted to we wanted
to show the talent and showcase the town
of the age of these and Canada and make
it something where you don't go and use
a rebate and escape you know you go to
use the talent euro to have the artistry
you go to have the complicit creation
with everybody there yeah s Guillermo
said we were very proud of the Canadian
talent and you know thirty years ago
when the business just started up there
the people up there began to learn from
the best in the world and now they are
some of the best in the world so we were
committed to using those people all
across the board on the film and we
think it's a great moment for Canadian
filmmaking obviously you know many more
Oscar nominations than any other film
for Canadians so we feel like it's a
real watershed moment we're very proud
we're going to 16 and I'm sorry we do
have to wrap up so I battery right here
to your right to your right to the back
a failure and when time for Latin
America I'm gonna say it in English and
Spanish so we all understand in English
is in Toronto when we talk you know
before the movie was released you said
that he didn't dare to dream about the
Oscar but if you had a chance he
wouldn't dare to write a speech and
prepare that so my question is did you
do well did you why did you think about
winning and what did you have left to
say so the in Spanish is in Toronto
cuando la mode a local repertory initia
vientre na dou y logistic a kuta meant a
no so yellow Kanu no carpet a tampoco
pretty was a people acting in a speech
in Tokyo e kikyo policy review a
listener the only time I wrote a speech
was a on the beginning and I pulled out
the paper and I couldn't read it and you
know I was sweating into my eyes and I
started just speaking from the heart so
what I wanted to do it I what I did here
is the same I thought you know I'm gonna
get there and if I have a little piece
of paper and I count down is horrible
could you see that the numbers go back
so I just let's talk about what you're
feeling at that moment did you have
anything left to say that you have oh
yes Lord I have a lot of cousins man
yes I did okay okay we're gonna move to
173 to wrap it up I write for the
Baltimore Sun and while we're very happy
and proud to have been the setting for
your movie
well what I'm wondering why it is why
did you choose Baltimore you know I mean
fell in love when I was a kid I fell in
love with one of the primal trilogies in
cinema for me is Barry Levinson's about
Baltimore trilogy you know and I loved
the setting and I we screwed up with the
accent I'm very very very aware with
that but what I what I wanted was to
capture that flavor you know it's such
an interesting mixture the Catholic the
the industrial how how nearest to the
ocean all those things and for me it was
mythical Levinson invented so many
things in those films and a particularly
importance for shape of water was a teen
man and the Cadillacs and ten men and
how they represent America and that is
in there you know I think that those
three films Avalon diner and
entertainment are fabulous landlords of
American cinema and then there's own
waters men